Google card they're coming they're gonna
be felt
driving they're not even have steering
wheel so in the car goes crazy won't
even have a chance people
but let's look at some specs from the
upcoming Google car
yeah so they're gonna have some
interesting safety measures like
flexible windscreen
home like material the maximum speed for
now 25 miles per hour so you're not
taking a cross-country trip on this
thing
they'll be button for start and I pull
over an emergency
topic anything crazy happen accord
sensors used for self-driving so that
they know
that there are yet another one is cool
cars or a regular car
and feeling for two passengers we've
also got a little bit DOT
up with the cool cars gonna look like
here
here hard no steering wheel in like
okay so starting in 2015 guy who's going
to start using these cars in states that
permit
up four states right now allow the
the testing a self-driving cars on
public roads California Nevada
Florida and Florida and Michigan so I
guess the first thing is
would you trust these vehicles this
seems kinda crazy you're putting a lot
of bade
in the machine all effin people have
brought up before
you know what if your car gets hacked
what if someone over ride
your computer if even if you have a
steering wheel you're still pretty
fucked in her family to
right I hate to break it to you I'm but
yeah there's a few things that aren't
accounted for here like what if you need
to
to wait for your you know grandma to get
out the car in the car what do you need
to go find parking
and a several stories tall parking
structure and untreated like
you know is being more than one story
taller whether they're so many little
things like you like on accounted for
right logically just are kinda concerned
a little I mean
but not fit not all situations can be
are I don't think it's ready yet you
know like what if any to park off road
yeah I don't think we're reading our
yeah I think humans are running through
is ready I got I mean I know they did
like studies at five thing years ago at
Stamford where they had driverless cars
and people freaked out granted been some
time since then
but still people are really incomparable
not being in control particularly a
moving object that the in our nature to
want to you
be in control of our feet and where we
move it makes no sense to be in a car
I think biologically our instinct tells
absolutely not right so before we fully
get to the hacking and all the evil
things that the machines are gonna do it
I think that
an interesting part of this that just
giving up the control
I mean just that just getting into this
thing and have been paid
that it's not going to get hacked into
or just something crazy
isn't gonna happen or someone else
that's driving because obviously we're
not going or change over I want someone
else is driving
normally is gonna just smack writing to
you anyway
you know like this there's a lot of
pieces here a good idea
all the cars are automated be great then
you know traffic could be cut down right
now ardently cut down
but when you're still counting on half
the time like other people
ability to not crash into you and kill
you
its not incredibly fortuitous
nursery ethical concerns that like
involve having all
automated cars to the like for example
on me know that there could be a case
where
crash is inevitable that one car had
three people on the other car has one
percent what
the car do who should the car protection
to protect you as like our owner should
can communicate with the iPad lol three
people there say those three lives and
kill you like
there also so many questions really well
call is there a phrase for those laws
that robots are gonna have to a bye bye
like for my robot like that kind of
thing where they're gonna have to say
like oh there's three lives in this car
one just as you said and they're gonna
have to make decisions
you know the work by keep making prime
directive I know that's not it
yeah cuz I Star Trek I have other
concerns about Karzai when I was
watching this video
I kept thinking about this how did I get
in this taxi
but more open you down
lol yeah felt bad guys breaking that my
point you're gonna happen Johnny Cade
going to be free get people out I am
better for a recall of course when my
favorite
I am 30 though it though when the
weather got held in the study they found
that if they have a little tiny robot
got a tiny robot in a driverless car
people are much more comfortable
yes i dnt do I would trust r2 d2
to control my vehicle I don't know that
I want to go but that even is
interesting because we still want some
level of human interaction there
which is why the when they when they
wrote that the maid
the guy looks sort of like but it's
scary that was far worse than having
about their
the okay so it's just that lets finish
up with the
with this machine's idea and the hacking
it all back anything
I mean if this step is inevitable that
shouldn't we be fighting anymore
should we be fighting it more you know
to me we're all walk around with these
devices that can be hacked into
we're all we're gonna be in cars that
can be had to do all this stuff and if
you have a question
already be hacked into parts can be
hacked into now with OnStar
well now's the time to be forming
legislation or are some kinda
figuring out how what with the order the
thing is and how it should work and we
should understand how it all works for
that we're able to you
voice our opinions affectively rather
than it being OK
Eurotech tight were all I'm you're
saying that our politicians should have
foresight commit to things that we know
are coming and they should try and
understand it
what you're saying that he is the
popular should understand something in
our politicians should have
foresight to deal with it something
knowledge equals
good world yeah that's why you are very
alert
those crazy dirty thoughts but they
don't bring us home on it
that was I others like me a verity but I
was thinking about
car ownership but how this can
potentially change that
how we may no longer oncars a baby comes
really cheap does have a driverless car
come pick about the my take is not to
worry about insurance or gas
where somebody driving it might make
sense and that kinda exciting because I
feel like it'll lead to
lower carbon emissions way right sorry
we brought that surrounded not
necessarily the car apocalypse so I I
kinda feel good about that